it's flu t2d Friday yes it is you know
Nate Tannenbaum has been playing the
flute now since fifth grade and he's
been preparing a song for us every week
now for the last few weeks which we've
really looked forward to so Nate
Tannenbaum what are you playing for us
this morning
okay so this is a song that was written
and performed years ago by Sting and
when it was first performed I have a
feeling that it didn't mean what it
might mean today especially if
somebody's getting into your personal
space at the grocery store
hopefully that's a hint for you here we
go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't stand so close to me
good job natal - with your selection yes
well and you know you have to be careful
and we all practicing that social
distancing but it seems like when you're
at the grocery store some folks are just
kind of getting up in your grill a
little bit you you hate to be rude to
them and even the grocery stores have
those squares not where you're supposed
to be six feet apart when you're
checking out right and we all need those
Plexiglas yeah what do you call them
yeah oh the face shields the shield yeah
right we all need those seams to harden
around glue keeping you at arm's length
don't get within one foot of my flute I
really look forward to that so we
appreciate wonderful nice job
thanks you guys